it is friday and it's time for the
mailbag you can email info at
davidpakman.com if you have something to
say sometimes we'll look at tweets
sometimes we'll look at youtube comments
um could be from anywhere let's get
right into it first one today indeed
does come to us from youtube it's from
john john says david why won't you talk
about hunter biden's laptop you must
support russia
ukraine and china
david you are our shame well another
unintelligible screed very common to
youtube we've talked about hunter
biden's laptop as a media story probably
a handful of times and of course i must
support russia
and ukraine
and china
those are all players on different sides
of the game different perspectives i'm
starting to think that john may not be
fully versed in geopolitics
based on this message
michael wrote in about the fox news mass
shooting response and says hey david
curious as to how fox news and other
right-wing types could possibly believe
that prayer in church is the answer
when the u.s is 30th worldwide in
percentage of atheists and i know you
know where we rank in the world for mass
shootings i am sick of these people not
having any responsibility for the
nonsense they spew out on a daily basis
it makes me want to quit paying
attention to anything political
hope is gone yet with all of these
things there's always some absurdity
where all signs point to guns as at
least a major factor that has to be
dealt with oh we don't have enough
religion well we have way more religion
than most countries
and we also have way more shootings so
if you want to look at that correlation
it doesn't bode particularly well for
god maybe god just isn't a factor in
this one way or the other and it's time
to actually look at guns i don't know
just an idea but
mike from atlanta
accurately
pointing that out
kristoff wrote in and said can we talk
about the irony that the people who for
the past two years were crying about the
psychological effect that masks would
have on children at schools
now want children to wear ballistic
blankets in case of a shooting and watch
their teacher shoot someone in front of
them yeah the the it's actually
multi-layered
and i tweeted about some of these things
on the one hand
the covet masks were irreparably
psychologically traumatizing to the kids
but wearing you know a bulletproof
backpack a ballistic blanket and having
their teachers be armed
is supposed to not have a detrimental
psychological impact that obviously
makes no sense but there's also the
hypocrisy when it comes to the teachers
the these are the very teachers that the
right wing has spent the last two years
saying
uh these are groomers
these are people
perpetuating the psychological abuse by
enforcing mask rules they're
indoctrinators they are wokesters they
are critical race theory teaching
indoctrinators who can't be trusted
let's give them the ultimate
responsibility of being armed in school
so that they can take out mass shooters
wait you've just said they're not even
capable of choosing the books your kids
should learn from and now you want to
give them guns it's completely absurd
and kristoff accurately points it out
anthony wrote in about the texas school
shooting
and says i thought your piece on the
texas school shooting was quite good
with one exception you didn't have time
to question how hardening the schools
with weapons is going to take care of
the movie theaters and grocery stores
and churches and all the other places
crazy people decide to go and shoot
people for fun how would the right wing
gun toting bible beating right to life
or solve that otherwise excellent work
david that's anthony from sag harbor
yeah this is a point that i made during
a live stream but anthony's right i
missed this during during our podcast
segment which is
even if you did all the stuff they want
to do at schools and even if it worked
which of course it's like they don't
want to deal with the gun part but
imagine you did it all
you can't do it at a ton of these other
establishments that have had shootings
you can't do it at the grocery stores
for practical purposes you can't do it
at the movie theaters
it's um
now
it's fair to say we need different
solutions to different problems that's
absolutely fine but again at some point
you've got to deal with the guns you're
not going to have solutions to all these
things without ever dealing with the
guns which is exactly what they want to
do
samuel wrote in about marcus flowers
um okay this this is an important email
samuel says david sir i applaud you for
recommending campaign involvement to
your audience but i really caution
against sending uh sending excess time
and donations to marcus flowers campaign
i worry too many progressives will make
the same mistake they made with the amy
mcgrath campaign in 2020
out of a passion to oust mitch mcconnell
only to see her lose big time
instead i would recommend efforts going
towards flippable races tim ryan in ohio
beasley in north carolina fetterman and
pennsylvania
and defending vulnerable incumbents
spanberger in virginia and slotkin in
michigan the truth there simply aren't
enough democratic voters to oust green
something something i obviously want to
see happen someday
in that district and the primary numbers
from wednesday reflect that in my
judgment it's better to keep green and
the minority then naively assume
we can remove her at this time this is a
completely fair point i'm never going to
say
ignore this race okay
but it is absolutely true
that the numbers in marjory taylor
green's district make it hard to believe
that in such a red district the
non-incumbent democratic nominee
flowers
is going to be able to win
now i'm not saying ignore the race but
we do have limited resources and i think
samuel makes an important point here
about understanding how to best use
those admittedly limited resources
keep it in mind
uh okay hannah wrote in and says
recession soon
hi david i'm hearing more news stories
that say the u.s is barreling toward
recession right now and that this
recession will start within the next
year do you agree why or why not thank
you hannah here's the difficulty of this
question
we may already be in a recession we may
be getting out of it right now we you
know
everybody defines it differently
understand that for a decade many have
been saying a recession is imminent uh
around 2015 there were lots of people
saying a recession is imminent imagine
if you had listened to them in 2015 and
said i believe the recession is imminent
i'm getting out of the stock market you
would have missed one of the greatest
run-ups in the stock market in decades
so my view is i don't know if a
recession is coming i can't control
whether a recession is coming at some
point there will be another recession
what do i know well i know my principles
i know that my principle is asset
allocation and my principle is low-cost
index funds without trying to time the
market and my principle is when the
market goes down
those same index fund purchases get me
more shares at a lower price because i
can't time it i don't know whether a
recession is coming and so i think a lot
of times the right question to ask is if
a recession were coming what what would
i do or what would i do differently
for most people the answer is well
actually nothing i wouldn't do anything
differently so i don't have the answer
uh about a recession but what i do have
is a plan
that is the plan whether or not we are
in a recession i hope that makes sense
niels wrote in with an idea for
when we get to 1.5 million youtube
subscribers and neil says hi david on
achieving 1.5 million subscribers may i
suggest you receive a colonoscopy on air
so
the joke here is recently
someone wrote in and said david you
should do a colonoscopy when you get to
1.5 million subscribers and the wording
was funny because typically it's the
doctors doing the the uh colonoscopy and
it's the patients receiving so i was
like are you saying that i should
receive one or that i should perform one
niels is clarifying that and saying i
should receive the colonoscopy when i
get to 1.5 million subscribers well
that's something we will look into okay
lucas has a different idea lucas says
hello david love your show i've been
watching the last two years now watching
your show reading suggestions for what
to do for 1.5 million on youtube i think
you should eat a carolina reaper it is
the world's hottest pepper and i feel
like it would gather a lot of attention
to your channel you should also set a
date for when you want to hit it in
order to eat the pepper i'm just going
to pass on that i am not interested in
hot peppers
uh i mean listen i love a good jalapeno
i'll use fresno chilies and cooking
dried thai chilies serrano for a
beautiful coconut cod chowder that i
like to make you chop up a serrano
pepper it's beautiful smoky heat
but i don't like stunts like this i
don't like eating contests and i have no
this is a no this is a hard no i would
sooner bleacher my hair or shave my head
than uh than do do this stacy wrote in
does a fetus have a right to get child
support
hi
if life begins at conception
shouldn't child support start at
conception yours stacy i've brought this
up many times before
um
the issue
about personhood at conception raises
really important questions
um if a fetus is a citizen
if a fetus is a person at conception
then it is a citizen right i mean it
should be able to be made a citizen
and even if it's the fetus of an
undocumented immigrant they should be
able to get citizenship
after conception because if it's a
person people get citizenship
if it is a person at conception then
presumably it would be entitled to child
support as well
uh it i mean listen
good luck actually having rational
conversations about these things with
the anti-choice movement but of course
stacy brings up a good point which is
it's less about when do we say life has
started
forms of life exist in so many places
and in so many ways and a fetus is less
about whether it qualifies as quote life
but
what is a person and what are the rights
that come with personhood because the
anti-choice movement wants to to talk a
lot about specific rights that they
believe a fetus should have
but not about many of the others that
people persons
also get
and it's an age-old hypocrisy as long as
roe v wade has been around all of these
arguments have been around and sadly
they very often become philosophical
black holes and you don't get anywhere
with them but an important question
info davidpakman.com if you have
questions comments suggestions that you
would like featured in the weekly
mailbag make sure that you are signed up
at
joinpackman.com get a membership get the
bonus show and get the commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
every day
six hours before
they are published to everybody
joinpakman.com is the place to sign up